I mean some people like you know in the
industry a lot of people will you know
do things for fame I just want to be
famous and then people do it because
they just love doing it I know guys like
yourself I don't care what I'm doing I
want to work I want to be on a show I
want to be acting I want to just do I'll
keep doing it and that's what they love
and it's
I I feel like it is so much a part of
them
that that's all they've known and that's
all they know maybe that
they can't change that's like if they
don't work they're not going to be happy
yeah I've definitely through covid now
have had an adjustment and through our
business which has changed drastically I
believe in the last six years but now
they're like for instance I have a show
I'm going out with with another guy
who's very known because it used to be
just you pitch an idea like and you
would just talk at lunch and be like
okay write it up and blah blah that says
yeah yeah you know how gone those are so
now you gotta stack your deck so I'm
with another guy who's a big producer he
has a deal we're going out and out of 10
networks so far
four
have passed to hear it four pass to just
hear it to hear it four
now you remember what we said earlier
about the numbers four don't even want
to hear it
now why do they not like me is there
mandates is there you know what I'm
saying like and this is a person that's
also very successful so it's
wild like that is and that just it's
hurtful well no it's just like if I
can't even get to the table when I've
already eaten and done
everything like
well I mean I'm looking I'm not invited
anymore yeah no it's like it's like and
and for what I'm fighting for a two
market share like to get through all
these hoops for less of a viewership I'd
rather just go on Tick Tock hey there
folks it's Michael Rosenbaum and boy
have I got a huge announcement for you
this has been a long time coming and
it's finally here
I'm doing a live podcast my podcast
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum is
going live yeah for the first time ever
on Wednesday October 11th at the iconic
Regent in Los Angeles and guess what I'm
not going to be alone
um we're bringing a guest you might
remember he's been on the podcast he's a
friend of the show the one the only
Zachary Levi we're gonna catch up on
life and mental health and we're gonna
have a really good time with all of you
I think you know that we're gonna make
it a lot of fun we're planning a q a
maybe some fun games other exclusive
stuff you're only going to get by seeing
it live we're even hosting a VIP meet
and greet for a small number of people
before the show begins grab your tickets
mark your calendars and get ready for
the night of laughs insights and
Unforgettable moments tickets are
limited so don't miss your chance to
join us on October 11th at the Regent in
Los Angeles get your tickets now at
insideofulive.com this is going to be an
epic night so if you're in the area come
out and I'll see you there
so it's it's changed a lot and it's just
like
so I mean it's just it's just the
ratings aren't the same you know
it's just a wild time so the business to
me is lost a little bit of its shine and
I'm not bitter man I'm like lucky I have
a great life yeah and I'm lucky I've
become somewhat of an entity so I can
always keep going but it's just like you
know I either self tape
or I'll get an indie you know what I
mean and hopefully one of those Indies
are great hopefully one of them pops
yeah I mean look it just happened which
I love them I'm sure you're good friends
with them with uh uh uh why do you
suppose name Simon Rex Simon's killing
it and think about it beautiful for a
while Simon was just kind of like you
didn't hear about him and all of a
sudden a little indie movie
yeah boom he's getting work everywhere
and he was phenomenal and he deserves it
and I love him and I'm so happy for him
yeah but look that's look every every
big Hollywood Story they want to see the
underdog they want to see the guy that
wants to get that gets back on top those
that's what a lot of movies are I don't
you know what's funny is a lot of those
movies aren't made anymore it's all just
either you know dude how many auditions
would you go on for a movie in a week
back in the day at least a couple or a
TV show
you would go on two or three auditions a
day for a movie think about this okay
Disney right Hollywood pictures Buena
Vista three different divisions each
making what 12 13 movies a year 38 39
movies okay I remember going on three
movies in a day for them
find like two in one week I had like six
movie auditions now what does Disney
make total
eight movies a year 400 million a movie
and they're usually animated or
something well some are animated but
then the rest are like 12 stars super
yeah right so there's the mid-level to
eight to ten million dollar movie is
done
and so it's just like how can we make
this huge piece of Pop Culture Americana
how can we turn it into a ride how can
we do it like where are the urban
legends those are going to streaming
where are the screams I don't would
screen be made you know the original
idea you know